whereas to simplify log base 5 of X the
3 and once again we're just going to
rewrite this in a different way you
could argue whether it's going to be
more simple or not and the the logarithm
property that I'm guessing that we
should use for this example right here
is the property if I take log log base X
of of let me pick some more letters here
of log base X of Y to the Z power that
this is the same thing as Z * log base X
of Y so this is a logarithm property if
I'm taking the logarithm of a given base
of something to a power I could take
that power out front I could take that
power out front and multiply that times
the log of the base of just the Y in
this case so if we apply this property
over here and in a second once I do this
problem we'll talk about why this
actually makes a lot of sense and comes
straight out of exponent properties but
if we just apply that over here we get
log base 5 of X the 3 well this is the
exponent right over here that's the same
thing as Z so that's going to be the
same thing as let me do this in a
different color that three is the same
thing we can put it out front that's the
same thing as three times the logarithm
base 5 of X and we're done this is just
another way of writing it using this
property and so you could argue that
this is a what maybe this is a
simplification because you took the
exponent outside of the logarithm and
you're multiplying the logarithm by that
number now now that out of the way let's
think about why that actually makes
sense so let's say that we let's say
that we know let's say that we know that
and I'll just pick some arbitrary
letters here let's say that we know that
a to the B power is equal to C and so if
we know that that's written as an
exponential equation if we wanted to
write the same truth as a logarithm
logarithmic equation we would say
logarithm
base a of C is equal to B to what power
do I have to raise a to get C I raise it
to the B power a to the B power is equal
to C fair enough now let's take both
sides of this equation right over here
and raise it to the deth power so let me
make it so let's raise take both sides
of this equation and raise it to the
deth power instead of doing it in place
I'm just going to rewrite it over here
so I wrote the original equation a to
the B is equal to C which is just
rewriting the statement but let me take
both sides of this to the dth power and
I should be consistent I'll use all
capital letters so this should be a b
actually let's say I'm using all
lowercase letters this is a lowercase C
so let me write it this way a to the so
I'm going to raise this to the deth
power and I'm going to raise this to the
deth power obviously if these two things
are equal to each other if I raise both
sides to the same power the equality is
still going to hold now what's
interesting over here what's interesting
over here is we could now say what we
could do is we can use our what we know
about exponent property say look if I
have a to the B power and then I raise
that to the D power our exponent
properties say that this is the same
thing this is equal to this is equal to
a to the BD power this is equal to a to
the BD let me write it here this is let
me do that in a different color I've
already used that green this right over
here using what we know about exponent
properties this is the same thing as a
to the BD power so we have a to the BD
power is equal to C to the dth power and
now this this exponential equation if we
write it as a logarithmic equation we
would say we would say
log base a of C to the dth power C to
the dth power is equal to BD is equal to
BD what power do I have have to raise A2
to get to C to the dth power to get to
this I have to raise it to the BD power
but what do we know that b is we already
know that b is this thing right over
here so if we substitute this in for B
and we could rewrite this is DB we get
we get logarithm base a of C to the dth
power is equal to BD or you could also
call that DB I'm just if you switch the
order and so that's equal to D * b b is
just log log base a of C so there you
have it we just derived this property
log base a of C to the dth that's the
same thing as D time log base a of C
which we applied right over here